so functional training is perceived by
some people as a bit of a dirty word
that's because the term can apply to
almost anything
leaving it wide open to misappropriation
what does it even mean to be functional
well being functional for sports is very
different from being functional for your
general lifestyle functional training
varies from person to person
but assuming a conventional lifestyle we
can still apply this term usefully in
the past i've argued that our bodies
naturally adapt to our environments
which includes our habits and routines
so if your main function is sitting at a
desk typing then your body will adapt by
giving you rounded shoulders kyphosis
and tight hip flexors
so what's the use in balance training
and mobility training if you're never
going to use it anyway
well the problem is twofold firstly our
lifestyles are far more repetitive than
they ever have been before while
adapting to your routine is good and
fine it becomes a problem if you're
constantly in the same position doing
the exact same thing for example if your
wrists are constantly flexed as you type
and use a mouse you're more likely to
encounter elbow and wrist pain
eventually
repetitive strain injury is less about
repeating the same movement over and
over and more about not moving with
enough variety there is not a limit as
to how many times we can move a joint
before it wears out
this particular issue for example can
often be addressed with pronated wrist
curls which just balances out the
muscles
the other problem is that the
environments change and injury occurs
when the environment changes faster than
we can adapt if you only ever sit at the
desk typing or on the couch watching tv
you'll be ill prepared for the moment
when you do need to move furniture or
lift the kid that is when your back is
likely to go out
likewise if you never engage in any
routine cardio you're going to struggle
to chase that bus or play a team sport
does a conventional weightlifting
program or cardio routine solve all of
these issues
often not
firstly a strength routine or cardio
routine will only benefit the relevant
issues strength training won't help you
to climb those stairs for example unless
you focus on strength endurance as well
secondly these activities are somewhat
niche in their approach learning to lift
a barbell is very different from
learning to lift a log or a fence
many programs fail to prepare you for
rotational strength which is applying
strength in a transverse plane
likewise there'll be times when you need
to round your back to pick something up
we need to strengthen our bodies from a
wide variety of different positions to
be injury proof and to perform at our
very best
so just how functional are you let's
take a look at some questions you can
ask yourself and some ways you can make
your training more functional going
forwards
can you get into a resting squat
mobility is for many people a bigger
issue than strength if you can't get
into a resting squat this suggests tight
hips and or ankles and perhaps a weak
core there are other reasons you might
not be able to get into this position
but the vast majority of us should make
this a priority
can you touch your toes likewise an
inability to touch your toes suggests
tight hamstrings calves and other
posterior muscles this can create
tension throughout your entire posterior
chain contributing to a rounded back and
hunched shoulders and it can lead to
back pain in the lower back it should be
a key focus for those looking to improve
functional movement
can you raise your hands above your head
this is another position we should all
be able to get into comfortably fixing
this general mobility will go a long way
to preventing injury increasing freedom
of movement and boosting a sense of
vigour for a lot of people
to properly test this stand with your
back against the wall and try and raise
your hands to touch it and don't let
your back arch move away from the wall
in the process you might think you can
raise your hands over your head but try
this and you might be surprised just how
limited the range of motion really is
do you have good posture and normal gait
film yourself standing and walking are
you hunched over do your palms hang with
a neutral position are you lifting your
feet off the ground sufficiently do you
move symmetrically where appropriate
do you experience regular joint pain or
muscle pain some joint pain is
unavoidable owing to previous injury or
ongoing illness however joint pain and
muscle pain are not normal and shouldn't
be treated as such if you've just
accepted your knee pain as a part of who
you are now or as a part of getting
older you may be doing yourself a
disservice
addressing muscular imbalances or
tightnesses can often fix issues that at
one time seems like life sentences
i've seen people who've experienced
joint pain for years eventually overcome
it
getting injured from time to time is
fairly normal if you're very physically
active but you should be able to recover
reliably and not to make that part of
your identity chronic pain is not normal
do you regularly tweak your muscles this
is an issue i suffered with for a very
long time
despite being pretty strong and fit on
paper i often put my back out during
mundane activities this could have been
an issue with mobility weaknesses in
smaller muscles or even proprioception
and movement patterns
for me lots of downward dog and more
rotational training has seemingly solved
this issue fingers crossed
do you get out of breath climbing the
stairs or running for the bus
if you regularly get out of breath then
you likely need to increase your cardio
even if you're incredibly strong if you
pant after climbing the stairs i
personally struggle to think of that as
being ideally fit
can you run and jump you should be able
to maintain a short jog sprint at full
speed without anything hurting and jump
off the ground with decent form not only
these fundamental human movements but
they might also someday save your life
can you perform a single push-up and
pull-up
barring atypical injuries or illnesses
most people should aspire to being able
to do a single push-up and pull up well
into old age this is a good indication
of your strength to weight ratio and
also requires a decent amount of control
being able to perform a pull-up also
means you should be able to pull
yourself up onto a ledge which again
could be a life-saving movement
can you lift 30 kilograms from the
ground and carry it
i thought on this for a while how much
should a person be able to lift off the
ground i'd love to hear your thoughts on
this in the comments down below
and should it be relative to their body
weight well i massively believe in
strength to weight ratio the truth is
that the world doesn't change when you
get heavier if you can lift 30 kilograms
you can lift most shopping most
suitcases and most small children and
this should be very achievable for most
people to aim for
again barring any injuries or illnesses
as well as lifting though you should
also be able to carry this object for a
short distance
after all in reality we are rarely
tasked with lifting something up and
then putting it immediately back down
can you balance on one leg if you can't
balance on one leg you'll be
significantly more likely to fall and
hurt yourself and limited in terms of
many other movements
do you feel constantly tired if you feel
sluggish and tired 90 of the time you
likely aren't working at your best
and you likely aren't extremely fit
either many people try to work out how
to get more energy they search for
things like why am i always tired but
they often neglect the simplest factor
of all exercise training will improve
everything from your vo2 max to your
stroke volume to your mitochondria
you'll sleep better too so if you're
otherwise fit consider speaking to your
doctor but consider first whether just
adding some more cardio into your
training could help a lot
can you focus on a task the brain can be
trained just like the body and just like
the body it can atrophy with misuse if
you struggle to focus on a task you may
need to consider interventions
can you rapidly switch between tasks
another example of cognitive fitness is
being able to rapidly switch between
tasks again your life could depend on
your ability to react quickly to a
changing situation
so that's just a small list of ideas
just some things that i came up with off
the top of my head i'd love to hear your
ideas in the comments down below
physiotherapists and other professionals
use a battery of tests to ascertain
basic balance coordination and range of
motion but as a quick and dirty way to
assess whether you meet basic fitness
requirements this list could be fairly
useful but now you've identified the
challenges you currently face what can
you do to address them any training is
better than nothing if you're running or
lifting weights regularly then you're
already doing great if not time to start
or alternatively take up a hobby like
rock climbing swimming walking or sports
or better yet a combination of those
but you'd be surprised just how many
people who are very strong or very fit
in some ways actually fail a number of
these tests so from there it's a matter
of looking at what's missing from your
current training if you're a power
lifter you might benefit from adding
some cardio and rotational strength
running and training with kettlebells
can offer these things
a runner might benefit from picking up
some weights to train their upper body
every form of training in every modality
offers its own benefits but by combining
these ideas from different places we'll
create a more well-rounded fitness
profile you might progress in each
activity a little more slowly than you
otherwise would have done you may not
hit that double body weight squat quite
so quickly but for the average person i
would argue it's more useful to be able
to move pain-free
i talk about super functional training
to try and address some of these issues
if being functional means being fit for
your daily activities being super
functional means being fit in ways you
don't necessarily need to be on the
regular because a sometimes you might
need that kind of fitness and b because
it's cool
as one viewer perfectly described
functional training is bruce wayne
training to be batman
but super functional training is
everyone else training to be batman
don't settle for good enough train to be
the best you can be physically and
mentally in every regard once you can
handle these basics it's time to set
bigger goals instead of push-ups how
about handstand push-ups instead of
balancing on one leg how about squatting
on a railing
of course if you like the idea of
training to be more functional or even
super functional you'll enjoy my ebook
and training program super functional
training that book is all about training
to improve not just your strength but
also your mobility your endurance and
even cognitive function all in a
well-rounded and balanced manner it's
linked in the description down below
anyway thank you so much for watching
this one guys if you found it useful or
interesting then please consider leaving
a like as that would help me out
immensely subscribe if you want more
like this and hit the bell button for
notifications either way thanks again
and
bye for now